[Music]
at least nine police officers have been
killed in a suicide bomb attack in
Southwestern Pakistan it happened in
Keck districts in the southwestern
province of baluchistan at least 11
others have been injured no group has
yet to claimed responsibility behind the
attack and let's go live now to Kamala
Haider who's monitoring this for us from
Islam about it Kamal what more do we
know at this point
well what we know so far is that the
attack took place in Bolan area of that
District it is about a large drive from
the provincial capital of baluchistan
which is
an explosion happened near a vehicle of
the baluchistan constabulary this is a
paramilitary force they were traveling
near a bridge when a powerful explosion
tossed over the the vehicle and a number
of people reported killed in that
particular attack we are also told that
13 people are injured of course the
police investigators are now saying
they're looking into the nature of this
explosion but this is not the first time
that the police or the paramilitary
forces or the regular regular military
forces have been targeted in baluchistan
there have been a number of attacks even
in the Northwest which is the khyberpunk
bench no one has yet claimed
responsibility but we are told that many
of the seriously wounded have been moved
to a military hospital and the death
toll is likely to rise because of that
all right Kamala back with you is weak
lean more thanks very much in the
meantime come on